i
[Música]
ah
en francia menos de la mitad de las
parejas tenían previsto celebrar san
valentín según un sondeo del instituto
francés de opinión una consecuencia más
de la pandemia pero también lo que
muestra un creciente desapego de los
franceses por una fecha que consideran
sobre todo algo comercial sin embargo
los jóvenes y tenían deseos de celebrar
este día sobre todo para reunirse y
cortar con una rutina en un país que
está semi confinado desde hace un poco
más de tres meses parís extraño a los
miles de turistas que vienen a celebrar
esta fecha pero para quienes sí estaban
en la capital hoteles y spas tenían
ofertas especiales los restaurantes
aunque cerrados tenían unos menús sanz
valentino para llevar y de hecho pues ya
que también los museos cines y teatros
permanecen cerrados al público la
oficina de turismo de parís proponía en
su página internet
ciertos recorridos por calles y jardines
de la capital todos estos claro para
visitar antes de las 6 de la tarde
cuando comienza el toque de queda
[Música]
en eeuu el día de san valentín también
se vivió de una manera especial y con el
contexto de el coronavirus en algunas
zonas del país siguen relajando las
restricciones a medida que el número de
contagios ha bajado ligeramente y los
restaurantes pudieron abrir para
celebrar esta fecha tan señalada eso sí
cumpliendo con todas las medidas de
seguridad sanitarias pero más allá de la
pandemia
miami cobra especial relevancia en el
día de san valentín y es que desde esta
ciudad se procesan la mayoría de flores
que llegan por aire y que luego se
distribuyen por todo el país el 89 por
ciento de los ramos y plantas se reciben
en el aeropuerto de miami y casi todos
llegan de países de américa latina como
colombia o ecuador que son grandes
productores de flores para la temporada
de san valentín se procesan más de 1100
millones de flores había mucha
incertidumbre por cómo iba a ser este
año la primera vez que se celebraba con
el coronavirus en pleno auge sin embargo
esta industria parece que es una de las
pocas que no se ha resentido de los
efectos negativos de la crisis el sector
confirma un aumento de los de los
pedidos en un
por ciento
[Música]
según las encuestas el 82 por ciento de
los chilenos celebra el día de san
valentín el 78 de ellos lo hace
ofreciendo regalos y se gasta una media
de unos 40 dólares aproximadamente con
los hombres gastando un poquito más que
las mujeres
en esta ocasión tradicionalmente los
chilenos celebran este día acudiendo a
comer o cenar a restaurantes para lo que
hay que reservar con varios días de
antelación se suelen ver largas colas y
restaurantes repletos en una fecha como
ésta sin embargo este año la pandemia
obliga también a cambiar los hábitos en
este sentido y muchos chilenos optaron
por restaurantes con terraza en el caso
de que la tuvieran como el que podemos
ver a nuestras espaldas o también por la
opción de la comida a domicilio que ganó
terreno ofreciendo menús especiales con
espumante parados por ejemplo o también
desayuno sorpresa que incluían por
ejemplo globos o peluches algunos de los
regalos tradicionales que ofrecen los
chilenos en un día como éste considerado
para muchos comercial en el que se
reivindica el amor
[Música]